after 10 days of protests across New
York Manhattan prosecutors are charging
Daniel penny for Jordan Neely's death
officials and friends say Neely
struggled with homelessness and mental
illness for years and he worked as a
Michael Jackson impersonator on May 1st
Witnesses say he was on the subway
acting erratically and screaming about
being hungry and tired that's when video
captured Penny helped by two other
passengers tackling Neely and putting
him in a chokehold
and he was questioned by police and
released the medical examiner determined
Neely's death was a homicide caused by
compression of the neck certainly a
reasonable jury would not believe that
Daniel Penny intended to kill Jordan
Neely but a jury could believe Beyond a
reasonable doubt that the actions were
not justified and that they were
Reckless